Thank you, everyone, for coming.
We're really excited to
be speaking here today.
My name is Mike Stackhouse.
I'm the chief innovation
officer of Atorud Research.
And with me, I have
Jessica Higgins, director
of analytics engineering.
But really, I'm a nerd
who likes to code,
and Jessica is a nerd who
likes science and coding.
Today, we're going to be talking
about our package, our R package,
Tplyr.
And where I want
to start with this
is a little bit about why we
made it, because typically I'm
speaking at industry
conferences that
are pharma-centric
and specifically
our pocket of pharma
that we work in,
which is late-phase
clinical trials.
So the first thing to
understand about programming
for late phase is that we're not
doing as much exploratory work,
which is what a lot of
the tools in the R ecosystem
is built for allowing you
to explore your data, model
and do all sorts of things.
But when you're in late phase,
a lot of what you need to do
is already laid out for you.
It's highly standardized.
You already have basically
all of the outputs
that you need to create.
So you're really trying to
operate more like a factory.
So the first kind of
principle of why we made
Tplyr, is that summary tables
are highly repetitive,
so your code should
be highly reusable.
You want to operate
like a factory,
you're putting out maybe 300
tables for a single trial.
So you need to get
through that volume
and you need to get
through it quickly.
So you really want to be
able to reuse that code.
The second principle is that
actually for the outputs
that we create,
summarizing the data
isn't what takes a lot of time.
It's easy enough to pop a
variable into count
or summarize and do some
means and standard deviations
and get those numbers.
That doesn't take much time.
The cosmetics of
getting it to look
the way that your
statistician acts asks you to
is what takes a lot of time.
So the other thing that we
tried to build in the package
is that text forwarding of
numbers or text formatting
of numbers can be very tedious.
So we wanted to make
it intuitive and easy,
but this package has been out
for two years at this point,
and I've talked
about this enough
that my team is definitely
sick about hearing it.
So the new thing that is the
last principle of what we've
finally gotten there
with is that we
want to make
Tplyr more friendly
for interactive tables.
So back in 2020, we work
with a lot of different SAS
programming groups
who are looking
to adopt R, and the question
that I get constantly
is, why R? And the point
that was made to me early
on that resonated that
I've never really forgotten
is that someone told me
that the cost of doing
an additional,
say, adverse event
table for a trial
within their company
is free because you just
pop it into a SAS macro
and out comes the
table and you're done.
And when you're trying to
talk about cost savings
and what R can do for you
in that area,
that's a hard thing
to compete against when
the output is free.
So what does R
really have to offer?
And that gets into the
world of R Markdown and Shiny
and interactivity, and
that's where we really want
to make things more accessible.
So just to give a little bit
of background on the package
itself.
Tplyr, it's an R package
that we released back in 2020
and I shamelessly took the name
from dplyr and the principle
from dplyr that it's
a package, a grammar
of clinical summary tables.
So the reason that we try to
make it a grammar of summary
tables is that we wanted
to take your focus off
of doing the actual summary and
thinking about the algorithms
that you need to write
to do the summarization
and how you get the
numbers that you want,
and really design it more based
off of describing the output
that you want to create.
So shifting that
focus of just saying,
this is what I want to
build. A statistician
typically what you
get your CSR and you
get the mocks of the tables
that you need to produce
and that's going to have
different characteristics that
are going to need
to be fulfilled.
So we wanted Tplyr's syntax to
focus on describing the output
and building up the
characteristics.
And then saying, go
and build this for me.
The last thing was that we
also wanted to really draw
our line in the sand.
I did not want to anchor into
any specific reporting package
itself.
I favored huxtable early on
because it had good RTF support.
Gt has been building up
over the last few years
and it's had an amazing place.
Jessica loves flextable,
and then in the Shiny world
you have things like reactable.
So I wanted to make the things
that come out of our package
really easily accessible
to any styling package
that you want to create.
And we just wanted
to really stop
at the character
formatting and the numbers.
So that annoying
part was done for you
and that you can pop it
into some other library that
will actually make it pretty.
I've never been good at that.
That's why I hired Maya.
So to describe Tplyr itself, I want
to thank Christina Fillmore
for giving me the best metaphor
for this that I've had,
which is think about cake.
So cake can take a lot of forms,
it can have a lot of flavors
and it can have a lot of
different decorations.
You can have multiple
layers into your cake,
and those things can look
differently depending
on how you build it up.
And that's really what a
Tplyr table ends up being.
So for a demographics
table, which
I have a concise
example of up here,
we have three different
variables from our data set
that are being summarized.
So we had the age group
of subjects, which
is a categorical variable.
We have age, which is
a continuous variable,
and then we have race, which is
another categorical variable.
So for the
categorical variables,
you're going to count, you're
going to represent percents,
and then for the
continuous variables,
you're going to do different
distribution or descriptive
statistics for your n,
mean, standard deviation, so
on and so forth.
And then those things are all
going to be combined together
and they're going to have
their different characteristics
of how you want that styled.
And we're going to bake
our cake and pop that out
and you get the dataframe
all collected together
and assembled and
ready formatted
so that you can go and put that
into some sort of presentation.
But our focus here today
and what we're talking
about for Tplyr today
is what metadata can
really bring to the table.
So the question that
we're trying to answer
and what we're trying
to make accessible here
is that when you look at
a result on the table,
asking the question, what
data produced that result?
So if I look at
this table, I know
that I have six subjects in
the low dose subgroup who
are Black or African American.
But who are the six subjects?
What are the data
that some or were
summarized to actually
produce that result?
If I'm looking at the median
of the high dose group,
again, what data
produced that result?
What subjects were fed in?
What was the data that went
into my dplyr summarize
and went through
the median function
to actually produce that result?
Because these are
questions that are often
asked when you want to
drill down into your data
and understand more about it.
So specifically, when we talk
about metadata within Tplyr,
we're asking two
different questions.
What variables were
necessary to derive
that result? And what filters
were necessary to derive
that result?
So really, what is
the slice of data
picking out the different
columns and the different rows
that were actually necessary
to produce the result that you
see on the table?
And here I will hand
it over to Jess.
OK so thanks, Mike, for
giving us a great intro
on why you created Tplyr.
And now we've talked about
what do we mean by metadata?
So how are we going to
harness this metadata?
So in this process
you've created
your Tplyr table, which
produces your summary
dataframe.
These are the results you see.
You would see them on paper
if you printed it out.
And additionally,
what we're doing here,
now, is that including this
table metadata, that metadata,
remember, those are the
names and the variables used
to create that result. And
we can use that metadata
to create the
relevant subset and we
can wrap all of this in a
really easy Shiny application
to create an interactive table
that, upon a click action, will
give us both our summary
table and the actual data
that produced that result.
So what does this look like?
And building it.
So how do you get that metadata?
How do you do you have to save?
It's very simple.
So creating the metadata,
all you have to do
is change the argument.
Metadata equals true.
And what will happen is
you're the metadata for this
for your table, we'll just
be created automatically.
For example, we have our
result output data frame
and now you can
see what's actually
added to the table is the
Tplyr metadata object.
So each cell contains this
object and this object
is the metadata.
Again, those variables,
those names that
created that
specific result cell.
As we were talking
about earlier,
this is indicated by a
row ID and a column ID.
And we can find go from there
to find who are these people?
They're not just numbers
in the summary table.
These are subjects
in a clinical trial.
So we've got this metadata.
How do we extract it?
What do we see?
Can we get to this?
As I mentioned, the
input is really simple.
You supply at a Tplyr table,
a row ID, and a column name.
And the output I really like
about this is that you can see,
OK, these are the names that are
required to create this result.
I already know what
columns I'm looking at.
These are the
filters and you can
see exactly what it looks like.
What are those, the filters
that are going into that result?
Saying, great, I see this.
Where the heck is that subset?
What is this data?
This is a really simple
function too. Again, give it.
It's a new function,
get meta subset.
You provide the
same inputs and it
produces that subset,
that subset of data
that produced your results.
You can see exactly
who is in that result.
Additionally, this get meta
subset function includes
an additional argument to
add relevant columns that
might give your subset a
little additional context.
It defaults to use USUBJID, which
is for those you in the clinical world.
It's a C specific variable
that these data sets have.
However, you can change
it to whatever you want.
This is the only place where any
clinical or C specific defaults
or language is used
in this package.
We really want Tplyr to be
extensible beyond just using
finished C-disc data, but this is
the one place where you see it.
So to summarize, we've created
our Tplyr table, which
includes our summary results.
We've got our relevant
metadata, our filters and names.
We can create the
subset to see that.
What does this actually look
like in an interactive table?
So let me give you
a quick little demo.
What you're going to see is
the most barebones, basic,
Shiny app ever created.
I'm actually I'm pretty
proud of this fact.
I didn't create it, but I could.
And I'm not a Shiny developer.
It's gone.
Here it is.
All its glory.
In fact, it's so simple.
It's 85 lines long, which I
had to look up and was again,
you can see the code.
We will provide that.
So what do we have here?
You can drive around.
So you want to see, as
we mentioned earlier,
we were looking at who are those
eight subjects in the placebo
group that are Black
or African-American.
You click on the result and
your metadata subset pops up.
You can see it, you can check.
So this is incredibly useful.
I as someone who spent a lot of
time looking at summary tables,
then looking at a
really long listing,
trying to find those
people individually
or programming it on the
side while you're comparing
at a summary table. To be able
to see all of these things
at once, to take your
review from a sort of very
manual process to something
that's interactive,
that's quick, that's fast.
It's just all about
what we're about,
trying to make things
quicker, faster and easier,
and to bring pharma
along in that process.
Slowly.
OK that's great.
Regular summary table.
These are pretty common.
What about if you want to?
When you want to.
If you were in an example of
where you have a summary table
and you've included some
additional statistical analyses
or models, and you have those
results that you want to share,
and you also want to include
the metadata for that test.
You want to know
exactly what subjects
went into that analysis.
Tplyr can extend
and append the metadata.
You can create a
new metadata object,
you can add those
filters and names that
will help created the results.
And in addition, and
my favorite part is
you don't actually need a
Tplyr table to do this.
This will work
with a data frame.
I was just recently thinking
about the context of this.
In my way former life, I was
an evolutionary biologist.
I worked with a
lot of butterflies
and used to  put them
in models and I was
like, man, if I could
have seen the subset that
would go into that at that
time, it would be really useful.
So I can see how I personally
would have taken this
and, and used it in my own work.
So again, extending
that metadata,
adding that metadata to you
directly to your results.
So you can pull
that up as needed.
Also quick this Shiny
up again, really simple.
So now we're looking at, we have
the results of a dose-response
model between
high and low, I think.
I can't see that well.
But again, you see who is
in who's in this model?
What are the subjects here?
What is the data that's
included in this model?
You can click on this really
simple interactive table.
And the results are produced.
And right there for you, it's
a really quick and snazzy way
to see your results and the
metadata that created them
all at once.
And with that, like
I said, we're really
excited at how we're sort of
getting some of these, the
idea of taking these formerly
paper clinical tables
and moving them
into more of a screen
friendly format
into a quick review
format in a way
that you can keep
moving forward.
Thank you.